welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
complete Marvel recap before Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania now everything
through Avengers end game is ancient
history at this point and covered in my
previous recap so watch those if you
need it this new Saga Begins with
Spider-Man far from home the world is
dealing with the after effects of the
blip when Thanos snapped away half the
population then five years later The
Avengers snapped him back with Iron Man
dead the world is wondering who will be
the next big hero it might be Peter
Parker Spider-Man or it might be this
new hero Mysterio but turns out he's a
villain he's a con man faking his powers
with hologram Tech Spider-Man finally
defeats him but not before he outs his
secret identity Peter Parker to the
world also the Nick Fury in this movie
turns out was actually a scroll
shapeshifter remember from Captain
Marvel they're good guys they're
recovering for Fury while he's off on a
secret mission in space so watch out for
that next up is the first Disney plus
series one division remember Wanda
maximoff and vision had a romance going
but unfortunately he was killed in
Infinity War but now the two of them are
living in an old school TV sitcom with
no explanation long story short she was
so sad over vision's death she lost
control of her powers and turned this
this whole town into sitcomsville where
she envisioned could have a family and
live happily ever after unfortunately
though she's accidentally taken this
whole town hostage we meet our new
Secret Agency sword which is basically
like shield in space we follow agent
Monica Rambo yes the little girl from
Captain Marvel and Monica Rambo travels
through the hex which somehow gives her
unspecified superpowers and the Scrolls
come to recruit her for Nick Fury space
mission meanwhile bad government guy
tried to weaponize original vision's
body but TV Vision talks him out of it
and he flies off but one of the side
characters the neighbor Agonist is
actually the witch Agatha Harkness here
to steal wonders Powers so Wanda and
Agatha have their final witch fight
where Wanda wins Wanda leaves Agatha
there but turns her back into her
character Agnes and Wanda does the right
thing takes down the hex to Freed the
town because she's not a villain even
though that means she loses her kids who
are not real but we're real to her next
up is the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
remember in end game old Steve Rogers
past the mantle of Captain America to
his friend to the Falcon Sam Wilson but
Sam's like look no one can live up to
that Legacy we should retire The Shield
but immediately the government names a
new Captain America this random
douchebag meanwhile Sam teams up with
his bickering buddy Bucky Barnes the
Winter Soldier to take down a nuke group
of super soldiers the flag Smashers and
they need help from a villain Zemo from
Civil War we didn't get to know much in
Civil War but turns out he's super rich
and kind of a hilarious guy and a great
dancer he takes them to the crime city
of madrapore where they also recruit
Sharon Carter who's also on the run
after Civil War now the flag Smashers
are kind of good guys trying to help
people displaced by the blip but they do
blow people up so not that good the new
Captain America John Walker tries to
fight him but they got super strength
they destroyed all the serum except for
one so he takes it and now he's a
full-on super soldier but when they kill
his friend he gets real mad and no no
kills one of them he defiled the shield
and now it's trending on Tick Tock so
Sam and Bucky fight him to get the
shield back and with a new wakandan
super suit Sam Wilson is the new Captain
America he does not have super strength
but he can fly so fair trade-off long
story short he saves the day Zemo goes
back to prison and Sharon Carter gets
her pardon but turns out she is the
mysterious leader of madrapora the power
broker so she's kind of a villain now
and John Walker is approached by Julia
Louise Dreyfus playing a shady spy type
character Val she puts him in a cool new
black suit and renames him the usage and
it seems like she's putting together a
team of Heroes that aren't afraid to
kill people next up is Black Widow yes
Natasha Romanov the Black Widow finally
gets her own Solo movie of course she's
dead now having tragically sacrificed
herself in endgame this movie takes
place right after Civil War when she was
on the Run where she has to take down
the new floating Red Room where they're
training a new group of Black Widow
assassins including one called
Taskmaster who's been trained in the
fighting styles of all the Avengers long
story short she blows it up and
unbrainwashes them all the important
thing from this movie is that Natasha
reconnects with her sister Yelena she
was a black widow too and is just as
badass as Natasha it seems like she
might take up her sister's mantle become
the New Gen Z Black Widow next up it's
Loki season one remember during end
games Time Heist they accidentally
knocked the space down to Loki he was
all set to resume his plans for world
domination but then some random people
came out of a portal and put him under
arrest they work for the TVA the time
variance Authority they monitor all of
time and keep people from stepping off
their preordained Destinies this
prevents a Multiverse from emerging
keeps it all a nice tight single
timeline this Loki's off his rails
they're gonna prune him but one agent
steps in it's Owen Wilson as agent
Mobius instead he recruits the this Loki
to help track down another more evil
Loki but turns out it's not an evil Loki
it's a girl Loki whose name is Sylvie
looking Sylvie team up to take down the
corrupt TVA along the way meeting tons
of other Loki variants then Loki and
Sylvia go to find out who's really
pulling the strings and turns out it is
just some guy now pay attention to this
part because it's important for
quantumania this guy's name is Kang and
he's a human scientist from future Earth
who discovered the Multiverse and met up
with all his other selves but some of
his other selves wanted to conquer the
Multiverse and so it started a
multiversal war so this one created the
TVA whose real purpose was to prevent
other kings from emerging by the way
these two fell in love but still be
kicks Loki away because she wants to
stab this guy and burn the whole thing
down he's like well guess you'll meet
new versions of me soon because without
the TVA new timeline start branching and
the Multiverse is here next up is what
if season one it's an awesome animated
show that explores this new Multiverse
as narrated by The Watcher who has taken
a vow not to interfere it explores cool
alternate timelines like what if instead
of Steve Rogers we got Captain Peggy
Carter the season one finale asked what
if Ultron won long story short he got
the Infinity Stones destroyed the whole
universe so the Watcher had to break his
vow recruited his favorite alternate
Heroes into the Guardians of the
Multiverse next up is chongqi and the
legend of the ten Rings meets Shang a
nice normal guy living in San Francisco
with his best friend Katie but when he's
attacked by some goons on the bus turns
out he's not so normal he's a Kung Fu
Master turns out his father was an
ancient Chinese warlord who conquered
the world with the power of the ten
Rings mysterious artifacts which made
him a video game character he created
the 10 Rings League of Assassins to
manipulate the world from the Shadows
his whole life he trained Chong to be an
assassin too but Sean's a good guy so he
ran away but soon their dad picks him up
and takes him to a secret ninja compound
they travel to the mystical Village of
talo where Pokemon are real they guard
the prison of the ancient demon who's
tricked their father into opening it and
boom Demon Lord out evil dad realizes
he's made a huge mistake and sacrifices
himself to save Chang and passes the 10
rings to him then shaan t with the 10
Ring Super Punch blows this thing up his
sister takes over the 10 Rings
organization and is it's unclear if it's
still evil or not but as for the 10
Rings themselves no one knows what they
are but when Sean put them on it sent
out a beacon so watch out for that next
up is eternals meet the eternals a group
of super space people who came to Earth
in ancient times in fact they inspired a
lot of cool Legends like Athena and
Gilgamesh they were sent here with one
job to fight the deviants these like you
know dinosaur monsters and they killed
the last deviant like a thousand years
ago so now in modern times they're just
kind of chilling we follow Cersei who is
hilariously dating Jon Snow but when a
deviant shows up her Eternal
ex-boyfriend flies in and I kid you not
it's Rob Stark they track down the rest
of the gangs like Kingo who's a
Bollywood movie star and they get a call
from their boss the giant Celestial
arsham he explains their real job was to
prepare Earth for the birth of a new
Celestial which would unfortunately
destroy the planet most of the eternals
have built lives here and are not gonna
let that happen but Icarus is like yo
it's our job so he goes full homelander
on him and it's a big eternals fight in
the end the emergence is starting so
it's up to Cersei to stop it by using
her power to to turn this whole thing
into marble Icarus feels real bad now so
he eats himself into the Sun so the day
is saved until their Celestial Boss
shows up he takes the eternals with him
like we're gonna have a talk and maybe
I'll be back to destroy the Earth later
meanwhile some of the gang is out in
space looking for other eternals and
they find one called Star Fox also Jon
Snow has a family heirloom that's a
magic sword so watch out for that next
up is Hawkeye meet Kate Bishop the
self-described greatest archer in the
world she's from a wealthy New York
family and gets wrapped up in a criminal
conspiracy who also investigating is
Clint Barton Hawkeye her favorite
avenger she basically forces him to take
her as a sidekick and these two do some
Arrow adventures together the leader of
the gang they're fighting is Echo who is
deaf and has a prosthetic leg but is a
huge badass also here for vengeance is
Yelena someone just put out a hit on
Hawkeye and Val told her that he killed
her sister Kate and Elena eat macaroni
and become new best friends and Elena
tells Kate that the person who ordered
the hit was Kate's mom who turns out
works for the big Crime Boss of New York
you know who that is it's Kingpin yes
Wilson Fisk from the Netflix daredevil
show now officially part of the MCU so
our archers team up to take him down and
save Christmas he's a really tough guy
though very difficult to kill Kate even
blows him up but he still walks that off
but turns out he's the uncle of echo who
just found out he had her father killed
and she shoots him but he'll probably
walk that off too so Kate bishop and
Clint Barton Saved Christmas and now
she's ready to become the new Hawkeye
and now it's Spider-Man no way home
after Mysterio leaked his identity
Peter's life is turned upside down so he
goes to visit his wizard friend doctor
strange it's like yeah bro I'll cast a
spell to make the world forget your
Spider-Man but Peter keeps adding
exceptions like Aunt May Ned and MJ and
so the Spell's unstable and wow what
happened it somehow brought in people
that knew his identity from other
universes like Dr Octopus from
Spider-Man 2. they gotta send these guys
back to where they belong so Peter
assembles team spider and track down
Sandman and Jamie Foxx's Electro and the
lizard and of course the Green Goblin
who is Norman Osborne's evil Gollum
alter ego but now the goblin takes over
and when it may comes to help oh hits
her with the glider and Aunt May dies
now meanwhile Ned discovered he can do
magic but he didn't summon his Peter
That's The Amazing Spider-Man Andrew
Garfield and yes they're all coming back
it's Toby Maguire too it's hilarious as
all three Peter Parkers become new best
friends and we get a triple Spider-Man
finale but wait the Green Goblin pumpkin
bombs the spell which Boom the only way
to stop it is not just to make the world
forget Peter Parker is Spider-Man but to
make them forget Peter Parker at all and
the spell Works everyone sent back to
their home universes and everyone's
forgotten all about Peter so Peter
Parker goes off on his own no more fancy
Stark Tech just your good old-fashioned
friendly neighborhood Spider-Man next up
is Moon Knight Stephen Grant is a nice
English chap who works in the Egyptian
Museum but he's been blacking out lately
and waking up in violent situations
turns out he has an alternate
personality a badass American Mark
Spector who is the superhero Moon Knight
they are the Avatar of the Egyptian god
konshu and the villain this season is
the Avatar of the evil crocodile God so
Moon Knight leaps into a action on an
adventure in Egypt but sometimes Stephen
takes over and isn't down with all this
violence long story short Mark and
Steven come to accept each other and
themselves and they work together to
save the day they get conscious to
release them as His Avatar but that
doesn't apply to their secret third
personality Jake lockley who speaks
Spanish and loves killing people next up
is Doctor Strange and the Multiverse of
Madness Dr Stephen Strange is defending
New York from an interdimensional
monster that's chasing this teenager
America Gomez America has unique
multiversal traveling powers and someone
bad's coming after her to steal them
Doctor Strange goes to recruit Wanda
maximoff to help but turns out Wanda is
the villain who's chasing after her
she's been corrupted by the evil spell
book The Dark hold and has gone full
Scarlet Witch her children exist in most
other universes she wants America's
powers to go out and be with them and
Wanda is real strong Doctor Strange
can't stop her she's gonna get America
but America bounced them out of their
multiversal trippy travel they land in
an alternate New York that instead of
the Avengers they have the Illuminati
that are alternate versions of our hero
Rose like Captain Peggy Carter and it
also includes famous Marvel heroes that
aren't in the MCU yet like Black Bolt of
the Inhumans as well as Professor Xavier
yeah from the X-Men and Reed Richards Mr
Fantastic of the Fantastic Four but
Wanda possesses her doppelganger here
and the Illuminati think they can stop
her but they're wrong it's not even
close she destroys them but now our
Strange uses the dark hole to bust out
some serious dark magic and Fight Fire
with Fire then America learns to control
her powers boom multiversal punch sends
Wanda to an Earth where her children see
her being an evil witch and she's like
yeah maybe I become the bad guy here so
she sacrifices herself destroying evil
mountain and erasing the dark holes in
all the universes at the end to Doctor
Strange meets purple Charlize Theron
who's like yo I need your help and turns
out he's got that evil third eye but he
seems to have it under control so watch
out for that up next is Ms Marvel Kamala
Khan is a teenager from New Jersey who's
a superhero Super Fan when she finds her
great grandma's mysterious old Bengals
she thinks it will spice up for Captain
Marvel cosplay but it does more than
that it gives her superpowers whoa she
defends Jersey City as the superhero
NightLight but pretty soon thinks that
name is lame and rebrands as Ms Marvel
she fights the interdimensional super
people the Jinn of which her great
grandmother was one and turns out her
powers don't come from the Bengal they
just unlocked what was already inside
fighter and here it is the mcu's first
m-bomb she's a mutant yes the X-Men are
coming back then at the end for reasons
unknown Kamala switches places with her
Idol the Captain Marvel Carol Danvers so
watch out for that now it's time for
Thor love and thunder in Avengers end
game Thor had let himself go but after a
quick workout Montage he's back to his
old self he had joined up with the
Guardians of the Galaxy but he's kind of
ruining their Vibe so they part ways now
someone has been killing other gods it's
this guy Gore whose daughter died and
when he looked at his God for help it
turns out most gods don't care about
people so Gore grab the nearby neck or
sword and killed him vowed to destroy
all gods he's coming for New Asgard so
Thor busts in to help but turns out
there's already another Thor here it is
his ex-girlfriend Dr Jane Foster his
hammer mjornir was still laying where
hella broke it but Jane Foster came and
if you be worthy you get the power of
Thor and yeah she's got the hammer back
and she's the Mighty Thor they try to
get help to stop Gore from the other
gods including Zeus but he's not
interested sounds like a you problem so
Thor steals his lightning bolt and out
stabs him with it Zoo survives though
and in the end credits scene he sends
his son Hercules to get revenge on Thor
now it's been a long time since Lauren
broke up and going on this adventure
together rekindles their romance
tragically she's dying of cancer and the
hammer only cures her temporarily using
it is just draining her more of course
gonna open The Eternity wishing well so
double Thor's team up to take him down
but they're too late he gets there gonna
wish to kill all gods but Thor's like
hey man why don't you just wish to bring
your daughter back he's like oh man yeah
that actually sounds better so instead
of choosing Vengeance he chooses love
and brings his daughter back to life but
now sadly Jane Foster dies but she turns
into going asgardus because she died as
an Asgard Warrior she gets to go to
Valhalla and without the neck or sword
Gore dies too so now Thor goes into
Daddy Mode as he's adopted this cute
little kid then it's She-Hulk attorney
at law Jennifer Walters is a nice normal
lawyer who turns out to his cousins with
Bruce Banner The Incredible Hulk after a
car crash they swap some blood and oh no
Jen hulks out cousin Bruce teaches her
how to be a Hulk when she picks up
easily can control it immediately but
Jen didn't pass the bar to be a
full-time superhero so she continues
practicing as a lawyer who sometimes
hulks out she gets a new job as a
superperson attorney and in fact her
first client is Emile Blonsky the
Abomination from the old Hulk movie just
like Bruce he's learned to control the
Abomination now and isn't really a bad
guy wants a new chance so she gets him
off on bro now this show is mostly a
comedy and the rest of the episodes
feature one-off hilarious metahuman
lethal cases and in one of them her
opposing counsel is none other than Matt
Murdoch he had a quick Cameo and
Spider-Man no way home but now he's here
for a full episode suiting up as
Daredevil and Daredevils back in the MCU
and Matt and Jen hit it off and these
two get it on all right at the end he's
meeting her family including her cousin
Bruce who turns out has a son from space
uh watch out for that now it's black
panther wakanda forever we begin with
the funeral of King t'challa who much
like actor Chadwick Boseman tragically
died of illness his mom takes over his
queen and the problem is the rest of the
world wants wakanda's vibranium now
there's no vibranium anywhere else in
the world except America just found some
in the ocean but these blue mer people
don't like that and now it's basically
Avatar way of the water their leader
visits wakanda he is not blue and his
name is Neymar he explains their
basically underwater wakanda and is like
we need to team up against the rest of
the world he's hunting the scientists
who built the vibranium sensor but turns
out it's just a college student Riri
Williams and she is a super genius in
fact she's built her own Iron Man suit
now t'challa's sister shuri is trying to
make peace with Neymar but just like
killmonger he thinks the only way to
keep his people safe is to conquer the
rest of the world and that's just not
gonna fly so Neymar invades wakanda and
by the way he's got Wings on his feet
and can fly around super strong he's a
mutant apparently and with his super
water balloons oh no kills sure he's mom
so now Shari's super sad goes into
science mode to build an artificial
black panther flower and yes it is jury
who's the New Black Panther she leads
her people on a counter attack gets
Neymar on land where he's weak but
instead of Vengeance she chooses mercy
and so wakanda and talakan make a truce
and at the end it turns out t'challa and
his girlfriend had a secret son t'challa
Jr so his legacy lives on and Val de
Fontaine shows up in this movie too
turns out she's the ex-wife of Everett
Ross so watch out for that now before
quantumania here's a quick recap on
Ant-Man remember Paul Rudd is Scott Lang
a burglar with the Heart of Gold who's
trying to turn over a new Leaf because
he just wants to be a good father to his
daughter gassy he's recruited by
scientist Hank Pym who's invented the
pin particle and the Ant-Man suit which
lets you whoa shrink way down or
sometimes grow real big and also somehow
control ants Hank has a daughter hope
who has a romance with Scott and he
builds her her own wasp suit so an
Ant-Man and the WASP Scott and hope team
up to get really small and go to the
quantum realm where Hank's wife Janet
has been been lost but they didn't stick
around there the quantum realm is still
a huge mystery now after the five year
blip Scott's daughter Cassie has grown
up to a teenager and of course don't
forget the most important character
Scott's best friend Louise who is maybe
even a better recapper than I am
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]